bueno América Latina tiene una situación
complicada del punto de vista de los
Derechos Humanos
sabemos que nuestros últimos años han
habido protestas sociales en los cuales
quienes comunican que de periodistas
comunicadores comunicadoras etcétera han
sido reprimidos también encarcelados por
ejercer su derecho a la libertad de
expresión y a informar a las personas y
por otra parte Hay a veces situaciones
de verdadero acoso judicial a hombres y
mujeres que ejercen el periodismo
convocando los continuamente a los
estrados judiciales por ejemplo para
absolver denuncias por difamación e
injurias que este la Corte
Interamericana decreta ha declarado que
en la convención Americana no es
admisible que en caso de un discurso
público
y que por actos en ejercicio la función
pública sean
sean este demandados penalmente las
periodistas y los periodistas que cubren
esa información entonces también a eso
se suma acoso en línea se suman coso de
otro tipo Entonces
es preocupante la situación de la de la
libertad de